welcome to Fox Sports coverage of the  day  hundred two hundred laps let's go  for the second year running the Daytona  500 goes with six times Sprint Cup  champion Jimmie Johnson  the rookie out of nowhere takes the pole  at Phoebe's Dale Earnhardt jr. wins the  Kobalt 400 Matt Kenseth wins at  Darlington David Ragan does it again  I'll Busch wins the all-star race Kevin  Harvick wins at Daytona missile gets the  Atlanta win a typically a big field race  and our rookie gets his first ever  Sprint Cup win at Richmond and makes it  into the chase  homestead-miami Speedway time to decide  the Sprint Cup champion in today  for 400  final lap and hoops going to take  Johnson Keselowski or junior but hearing  come he's making his move on the inside  you